how are you doing today i'm doing very
well thank you how are you
i am incredibly excited to talk to you
about this movie i i loved it so much
i'm so glad to hear that that's that's
great news
i'm sure everybody who's coming in the
room to talk to you is going to be
raving so you know um enjoy your it's
going to be a tough day doing press
it's lovely to get feedback to know that
people people have been waiting so long
to see the project and
it's lovely to know that yeah the hard
work that we've put in is it's it's
worth it for sure um it's nice to hear
that so thank you
of course there are so many things to
rave about this movie but i'm curious
when you talk to your friends and family
what are the things that you keep
telling them about this movie like you
cannot i can't wait for you to see this
i have a friend who as soon as she found
out i was doing this
she's like oh my god the ornithopters
she absolutely went she went crazy wild
and i was like
i didn't realize that she was such a fan
and there there are so many people that
i know who have had this book in their
life since they were children who
i've i never i've never seen them geek
out in a way that that they do it's it's
so it's it's it's real a real eye-opener
to see the june who the dune fans really
are this they're different they're
different to
the i don't want to say the average
sci-fi fan because that's not fair
either but it's they're not what they're
not what you expect and um you know i've
had lots of people telling me about
their their moms their mother-in-laws
people who are in their 60s so it's just
it's it's wonderful to know that the age
the age um the ages of all the different
fans are it's so vast it's a world that
that for one so many people can come
together in an appreciation of
one of the things is that this film and
the book have these great powerful women
and the way that it was it was written
in the 60s which was obviously highly
unusual but can you sort of talk about
that aspect of dune because i think
that's one of the strengths of the film
yeah it's it's it's the one thing it's
one of the main things that i i i state
very clearly when i talk about frank
herbert's writing he's a
forward-thinking kind of guy because not
only do you have these women who are are
present
and strong and vocal but there there's
there's more than one of them this is no
it's never normally the case even now
you know you see projects coming up now
and it'd be a story or a film it's
normally just the one so to have to have
a few
it's and then of course as we know how
the dynasties roll out with the rest of
the storytelling there are more to come
which is extraordinary and
he to me that's that's how things should
be now so the fact that it occurred 60
or almost 60 years ago it's it's
i salute the guy and say thank you very
much because i wonder if he hadn't have
done that what would things have been
like
now
um you know he's he influenced so many
aspects of of sci-fi storytelling that
you gotta know well
yes
there need to be more and this is this
is the conversation that we're having
today it's there needs to be more of us
females on screen but um he was ahead of
his time so
i always keep questioning
what would frank have written now and
how how would things have been different
and i that that for me makes me
i i take a certain
a certain amount of um confidence in and
knowing that he would have been once
again even further along than we are now
which is how how do you think about that
i guess it's about having the
conversation and putting things out
there and saying you know really getting
on with it but he
extraordinary human being is what i
think
i completely agree i already got a rap
i'm just going to say again congrats i
hope it's a huge huge hit
thank you very much thanks a lot take
care